[Music]
eight-time olympic gold medalist
usain bolt just had a little girl
it took him this long he's so fast in
life but then
when it comes to baby took him a long
time what's your name i want to know
what the name of the uh kid is
dopest name ever is it sparks this girl
insane bolt insane oh cause it's like
both
okay lightning bolt lightning bolt no
lightning bolt
her name is olympia lightning bolt wow
oh i was right again oh no
you weren't he said lightning bolt oh he
did yeah
yeah he said sparkle no that was first
yeah yeah look olympia lightning damn
so she was actually born back in may but
just recently he posted
a photo of her and his girlfriend
with the baby oh damn
so cute but everyone's like
damn that's a name like a name to live
up to
olympia lightning she better be like the
best athlete in the world
what if she's like the opposite exactly
that's why i feel
i feel for this girl just like a super
fat chick that's just like my name's
lightning bolt
that's like opposite olympia should they
call me thunder
oh no girl dad it's so cute
i don't like that when they like they
try to like make the kid like live up oh
you're not as good at your parents and
they just have to live in that like
that's what they're doing all the time
especially all these like like these
kids of like yeah like the basketball
stars
michael jordan yeah and they're like oh
you're not as good as your dad i'm like
yeah but when it works out
your dad's not as good as my dad either
[ __ ] that's a good one i'd
rather have my dad be michael jordan
you're a loser
but also like it's hard to live up to a
great
like i don't know anyone that surpassed
their dad or mom and if they're if their
dad or mom is a great
you know what i mean like i don't know
someone that they always live in the
shadows okay that's why
i i don't strive to be great you know
isaac
pass you up easily he has a pretty low
bar to pad you know
i'm just like just do whatever the [ __ ]
you want don't copy me that's what i'm
saying
you know it's like why the [ __ ] do i
need them to live up to my [ __ ] it's
like
are you always looking at me dude i
don't just do your own [ __ ] so obsessed
with me
[ __ ] that part if you are good at
something though you know how you can
shut up about it not just you but
anybody right
so like you might not even be thinking
you're pressuring your kid to do it
but like let's say anthony he's like
talking about [ __ ] dance all goddamn
day his kids my [ __ ] my
all my dad ever do is talk about dancing
i gotta be a dancer too
well i get like the the normal stuff
like basketball and things but well look
my dad was a uh uh
not he was not just a boy scout he was
uh he was a scout master he like started
boy scouts
what uh in terms of like the troop out
here
there was vietnamese boys so when i was
in a vietnamese boy scout troop out here
when i was younger
i feel like uh everybody knew who i was
because i was his
son and it was a tough shadow to be in
but i also believe that if i
didn't live in his shadow i would not
have become as good as i did
because i was pressured to and you're
still striving hard to be you know what
i'm saying and i'll never be as good at
at it as him but because of that shadow
i was forced to try and be better than
everyone else i had this like mentality
in my head where it's like
i felt the limelight and the pressure to
have to be better than every other boy
in that scene yeah i feel like it has to
be in your dna to have that like
that competitive nature yeah like that
com exactly because
for example for me sure but you gotta
have the environment too for that to
activate right yeah
because like for me honestly like if i
wasn't like if i was olympia i'd be like
[ __ ] why even try i'm
never going to get this environment
though because you even said that you
used to be hella adventurous and
hyperactive until
environment brought you down true so
then
you might have been an athlete you might
have i don't know if it's quite dna
i think it's i think a lot of it has to
do with environment and cultural
and upbringing and [ __ ] i knew a kid in
high school
um whose dad was like the wrestling
coach there and he was on the wrestling
team and i guess like
he like lost this big match and then
like the kid himself like started crying
because
he felt bad that he couldn't live up to
his dad's like coaching
that's natural that's kind of natural
right right he's disappointing his team
yeah his team and his dad and then
his dad is his coach and his dad so it's
like double disappointment yeah
well think about like kobe and gigi
right like rest in peace but like you
know she was
do you really think that she was going
to be the person who's going to change
the wnba
true if her father wasn't kobe bryant
you know what i'm saying
yeah like be a part of not just even
like the mom of mentality like entire
camp but like
literally and not even just the coaching
just the the love of the game basketball
yeah right
that part i mean you could easily say
then what about his eldest you know she
never liked basketball she never wanted
to be
which is which is what what makes the
conversation actually fine for somebody
like olivia lightning
olympia lightning bolt right because
it's like oh like how they're gonna live
it's like kobe had an older daughter who
didn't have to play basketball it
happens
right it's just more the idea i don't
think they can live up to his
greatness true i mean it's difficult
it's difficult i'm just saying it's
difficult to live up
to the level of if you're in the same
thing yeah like
it might be like like angelina jolie
right like her parents were actors
i don't know if they were great actors
it's just not my era right
but i think she surpassed them as far as
i know from my era
right and then there are musicians kids
that
do their own thing and then like you
know but i don't think they do the same
thing so if it was like a jazz musician
and a jazz music
jazz kid i don't know if they'll make
the mark in the same thing
that king cole's daughter like she's
really good for herself
you know but she's not like a good girl
but is she not keen cold because like
the greats are also they're also just
called a great because they're greater
than anyone else in the human race
yup so it's not even just a family it's
just there's no other human that has
ever been
this good that's true but if they apply
that
work ethic and talent or whatever they
learn from their parents and then they
go to a different field
i've i think that happens it's gotta be
the other way as well too though right
like um
uh jim carrey's dad was a comedian right
oh he was
yeah he passed that um right yeah
i don't know what the [ __ ] is that it's
smoke is that true
denzel washington's son has a chance
around even though denzel washington is
great he has a chance i don't know if
his son will pass him
yeah he just he's in all kinds of movies
and she's the new uh intent
yeah he's the new guy in tennant he was
uh he was on balls in hbo with the rock
he was uh
uh was it black has been malcolm
washington or john david
i'm david washington i also think if
it's athletic
compared to more of like a creative
skill you have more of a chance because
uh athleticism is
genetic and in your dna yeah so her
first day
just because if she has like more of her
dad's jeans her first day in pe she
might be smoking the [ __ ] out of kids
right
some people when they're writing like
the journalists they were like man this
newborn baby is probably faster than me
already
she might be like i [ __ ] suck at this
yeah they'll always be in the shadow of
their parentage if you will and they're
really good
but they're going to be better than
everyone else in their community
it's like it's hard to compare to
because it was in that time there
one like usain bolt's so great but how's
that lineage right
she could probably grow up she's never
going to be able to compete against him
right or say like uh he has times but
this is like a nightmare
to beat his record or whatever can she
change the game is what i'm saying
because that's what makes someone great
yeah you're changing the game he changed
the game beating records and
enormously it's just no one could beat
him he's like all-time winning like
eight gold medals
it's even harder to get one right yeah
it's like back to back to back to back
and like he's
when you see him run to and when he he's
like
many steps ahead of everyone else yeah
it's crazy that's cool that's like
having a superpower that's funny
his daughter is many sex superpowers and
many people right now
but i would say that the way humans
develop a need to compete or want or
whatever
i think it's highly dependent on how
they find significance as a child so for
what that means is like
let's say if your dad is really into
running right and you wanna
and then you get a positive reaction
from him when you start running because
they're like oh my god you're into what
i'm into
and then you get attention so then
because of that i think
you strive for it and then some people
identify with being number one
because that's how they that's how they
get common ground for love
so then if you never had that from your
parents i don't know
if it's not everyone manifests
competition and wanting to be
good this way but i think a lot of
people at an early age
they develop the need to succeed and all
that through this way that makes sense
yeah
but i think it's also with like see a
lot of these people that are the
greatest they also come
from like maybe nothing you know they
don't have like something before them
they don't have
it makes the story great right it makes
the story great it makes them then it
gives them a reason to
fight for something right that's true
like how you look at or how like a lot
of people
look at kylie jenner for example like
she's done a lot
on her own but then people don't really
fully give her the credit because of the
fact that she was already born into
wealth she was born into like
having a leg up already yeah but even
with the not with the other people
uh some of these people they're like
yeah they want it but they don't have
like if you're gonna be a fighter
like a lot of these fighters only like
there's some outliers like jordan say
pierre and stuff that like they don't
they're not
come from like super poverty or like
that crazy like like jose uh
jose
he was the one fighting with the kimball
slice videos he was fighting since came
back the other day he came from the
streets and like
all the like same thing with um conor
mcgregor like all these people
i think who park i don't know that on
the streets no we're talking about like
he's a husband i don't think he was ever
that i thought you got to be something
to be a has been though that's what
i'm saying and he has no shadow to live
up to so his environment really
yeah you guys hate this mom though the
mom was crazy yeah
his mom's crazy mom's a great it's
hardest passer see yeah
that's true what do you think taika
like what kind of pressure is tech is
going to grow up dude geo shadow is huge
it's a big shout out i'm in the shadow
[ __ ]
it's a big [ __ ] shadow dude yeah
cause already people are like man this
kid's
buff he's gonna grow up being like
insanely
like do you ever feel like you yourself
are gonna
somehow pressure him unknowingly like i
don't think do you feel that do you feel
that asian momness where you just
identify like you know stage moms right
they push the [ __ ] kid because in
reality they don't got [ __ ] for
themselves
or like they're living vicariously
through yeah yeah a lot of asian parents
do that
yeah no i actually don't feel that
because i think he's actually more
competitive than i am
like the amount that he can get riled up
and he has to do something his way or
whatever
he's already has like this energy of
like
you got to get that [ __ ] out so like i'm
like oh cool like i don't feel like
you know like some some dogs you have
like you open the door and like
do you wanna go outside and play come on
go outside and play get some sun you
gotta drag the [ __ ] dog out and the
dog is like i still don't wanna go
outside
he's the guy that's like oh get me out
let me get out there so the minute you
open the door he's already out so i
don't think i have to motivate him to
like go do
things i think i just i'm just trying to
like really read into
what he wants to do and i can like
channel it in the right direction not
even have to motivate him but even just
being like acknowledging that he likes
something for example like do you feel
like
your inner like tigerness is going to
come out you're going to want to be like
now you have to be the best at this
thing that you like um no because i
like basketball and he likes baseball
and we play more baseball
so it's just like whatever he likes so i
don't go like this is what i like if you
pick something basketball
it would be like subliminal though right
it would be like ty can you do whatever
you want but then there's a giant flag
behind him says dominate humbly
it's gonna be like that you know what
i'm saying like why do you need to say
that you also don't know
yeah you also don't know what were you
saying like uh we saw what tiff's saying
like say okay then he wants to do
baseball
are you gonna like be there to make sure
that he's the best and try to make him
like
the strongest and everything oh no i
don't care it's just whatever he wants
and like for me it's like i just don't
want misplaced energy
so whatever his energy is at if it's
like you know like cyclops already
[ __ ] takes off the glasses
i just want to make sure oh he likes
baseball then i'll channel all that
laser into the baseball
and then i'll just let him get his own
energy out there
after five years he goes i don't want
baseball that's cool that's [ __ ]
challenging i think it's good what if
he's like
top three he's like borderline making it
yeah
if he's about to break through a
threshold i think i will push him so
that he can get
past that threshold because you're just
so close if he wants that
if he wants it because then i also do
believe if like if you know
sometimes people don't know how close
they are to the top of the mountain
and then being a parent i also want to
see him go [ __ ] you were like
an inch away from the top of mount
everest and you came back down what if
what if like taika is like participating
in like several
sports but he doesn't like him because
he keeps losing in them would you
insist that he should like still try to
give it a go and try to at least win one
game
like he's like highly competitive and he
just lost one game he's like [ __ ] it i
don't like the sport anymore just
because i lost
there yeah there are kids like that i
would because that was one of the
biggest lessons i learned where um
this so when i was at brown belt and
kung fu uh
that summer i went to taiwan i spent
like two months there you know when
you're a kid like
you don't you remember who were you i
forgot but you learn
you forget [ __ ] as quickly as you learn
it so two months of not doing forms or
anything
like i came back and i was supposed to
go back to kung fu class i remember
crying at home i don't want to go i want
to go
don't remember anything anymore i don't
even know how to do a horse dance
and my mom's like just go in no pressure
don't even wear your brown belt
you just go in the class go in the white
belt class and then
in a week i picked everything up you
know like he just came back and then
eventually i got my red belt and i got
my black belt and then that was like one
of the most proudest moments of my
elementary life
so i'm like oh you know it's interesting
that um i
i kind of struggle with myself is that
when
you are a parent you want to use your
own
experiences to help your kid not make
the same mistakes
but the part where we tend to forget is
like oh [ __ ] they're their own person
they're their own they have their own
their own perspective on life they have
their own emotions they have their own
world their own lives exactly and so
like
um and so when it comes to that there is
like
um like a a balance of inserting
yourself
to try to like guide them but also
understanding where they're at so you
can guide them
through their journey so i'm like [ __ ]
that's just hard that's the hard part
yeah or it could be like our parents and
be like shut the [ __ ] up and do it all
[Music]
right
you